[Music]
i left the university of wisconsin in
1931
to find myself in an america sadly
dislocated an america offering few
opportunities for
young energy and enthusiasm i was
smitten with the usual
wanderlust the united states did not
seem adequate
i looked around new york for a job there
were no jobs to be had
something seemed to be wrong with
america i decided to go somewhere else
i began to read extensively about the
soviet union and gradually came to the
conclusion that the bolsheviks
had found answers to at least some of
the questions americans were asking each
other
i decided to go to russia to work study
and to lend a hand in the construction
of a society which seemed to be at least
one step ahead of the american
following wise parental council i
learned a trade before going
i went to work as a welder's apprentice
and several months later received a
welder's
certificate armed with this with
credentials from the metalworkers union
of which i was an active member
and with letters of several personal
friends i set off for berlin
where i applied for a soviet visa the
welding trust was glad to give me work
they needed welders in many places
finally arrangements were completed and
i started out on the four-day train trip
to a place called magnetogorsk
on the eastern slopes of the euro
mountains i was very happy
there was no unemployment in the soviet
union the bolsheviks planned their
economy
and gave opportunities to young men and
women furthermore they had got away from
the fetishization of material
possessions which my good parents had
taught me
was one of the basic ills of our
american civilization
i saw that most russians ate only black
bread wore one suit until it
disintegrated
and used old newspapers for writing
letters and office memoranda
i was about to participate in the
construction of this
society i was going to be one of the
many who cared not to own a second pair
of shoes
but who built blast furnaces which were
their own
it was september 1932 and i was 20 years
old
all during the 30s the russian people
were at war it did not take me long to
realize they ate black bread principally
because there was no
other to be had wore rags because they
could not be replaced
in magnetogorsk i was precipitated into
a battle i was deployed on the iron and
steel front
while political leaders in moscow were
scheming and intriguing
planning and organizing i worked in
magnetogorsk
with the common soldiers the steel
workers the simple people who sweated
and shed
tears and blood for five years
i worked in magnetogorsk i saw
a magnificent plant built i saw much
sweat
and blood and many tears
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so this christmas magellan are offering
a two-for-one deal on their
subscriptions
so you can buy a subscription to
magellan for a year for two friends
and so i've done that here for coco and
salam
so coco's obviously very excited because
she loves documentaries and magellan has
more than three thousand
uh and salon salam are you excited
oh oh no buying a gift card will also
get you a free month of magellan
now's the time to share all 3 000
documentaries and chat about them at the
christmas table
and my recommendation this week is an
eye on you
a fascinating exploration of modern
states emulating the methods developed
during the soviet union for those of you
who don't know magellan is a sort of
netflix for documentaries
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voice of the past viewers
and also to get involved in the
fantastic two for one
gift card deal thanks
[Music]
the big whistle on the powerhouse
sounded a long
deep hollow six o'clock
all over the scattered city camp of
magneto gorsk
workers rolled out of their beds or
bunks and dressed in preparation for the
day's work
i climbed out of bed and turned on the
light i could see my breath
across the room as i awoke my roommate
kalia
khalia never heard the whistle we pushed
our coarse brown army blankets over the
beds
and dressed as quickly as we could we
did not eat anything we had nothing on
hand except tea and a few potatoes
we locked up and set out for the mill
it was january 1933
[Music]
the temperature was in the neighborhood
of 35 below
a light powdery snow covered the low
spots on the ground
a few stars crackled in the sky and some
electric lights twinkled on the blast
furnaces
otherwise the world was bleak and cold
and almost pitch dark it was two miles
to the blast furnaces
over rough ground
[Music]
down beside the foundation of blast
furnace number four
there was a wooden shanty the men
gathered round in an ever widening
circle
smoking and talking
by the time the seven o'clock whistle
blew the shanty was jammed full of
riggers
welders cutters and their helpers it was
a varied gang
russians ukrainians tartars mongols jews
mostly young and all peasants of
yesterday though a few like
ivanov had long industrial experience
on the other hand kaibulin the tartar
had never seen a staircase
or a locomotive or an electric light
until he had come to magneto gorsk a
year before
his ancestors for centuries had raised
stock on the flat plains of kazakhstan
his life had changed more in a year
than that of his ancestors since the
time of tamerlane
[Music]
on the way to the furnace i met shabkoff
the ex-culak
a great busky youth with a red face a
jovial voice and
two fingers missing from his left hand
well jack how goes it
he said slapping me on my back my
russian was still pretty bad
but i could carry on a simple
conversation and understood almost
everything that was said
badly i said that doesn't matter he said
if you lived where i do in a tent you
wouldn't think it's so cold here
i know you guys have it tough said papa
who had just joined us
that's what you get for being kulax he
laughed
tell me though how did they decide who
was to be decoolicized
ah said shapkov that's a hell of a
question
just between the three of us though the
poor peasants of the village get
together in a meeting and decide
so and so has six horses we couldn't
very well get along without those in the
collective farm
besides he hired a man last year to help
on the harvest
they notify the gpu and there you are so
and so
gets five years they confiscate his
property
and give it to the new collective farm
sometimes they ship the whole family out
when they came to ship us out my brother
got a rifle and fired several shots of
the gpu officers
they fired back my brother was killed
all of which naturally didn't make it
any better for us we all got five years
and in different places
i heard my father died in december but
i'm not sure
shapkov got out his canvas tobacco pouch
in the roll of newspaper
and thrust both towards pop off kulak's
smoke
he smiled grimly
[Music]
at this point a young boisterous
athletic looking burner burst
into the room and pushed his way up to
the stove boy is it cold
he said addressing everyone in the room
i don't think we should work up on top
today
one of the riveters froze to death up
there last night
yeah said everybody at once who was it
but nobody knew who it was it was just
one of the
thousands of peasants and young workers
who had come to magneto gorsk
for a bread card or because things were
tough in the newly collectivized
villages
or fired with enthusiasm for socialist
construction
[Music]
it was just about 9 15 when i finished
one side of the pipe
and went round to start the other a
scaffold was coated with about an inch
of ice
like everything around the furnaces i
was just going to start welding when i
heard someone sing out and
something swished down past me it was a
rigger who had been working up at the
very top
he bounced off a bleeder pipe which
probably saved his life
by the time i got down to him blood was
coming out of his mouth and gushes
he tried to yell but could not after
lunch shimichkin the superintendent
arrived
then came mr harris the american
specialist consultant with his
interpreter then teshenko the burly
sinister prisoner specialist
well said mr harris sue the interpreter
when do you expect to get the rest of
the riveting done on top of number three
toshenko the chief engineer convicted of
sabotage in the rams in trial in 1929
sentenced to be shot sentence commuted
now serving 10 years in magneto gorsk
shrugged his shoulders he was not a
worthy man
he'd heard a great deal of talk since
1917 and
had decided that most of it was
worthless
shivchenko entered the assistant
director his main energies were directed
toward finding
objective or political excuses for the
failure of his organization to adhere to
the super ambitious
moscow construction schedule which
everybody knew was impossible to fulfill
mr harris was jotting down figures on a
piece of paper
now mr chevchenko said the american
orders are orders but you can't rivet
steel without them
and you can heat rivets with them we
must have those rivets or the job won't
be finished by next christmas shivchenko
knew that this was sound
however harris's remark created a
situation in which it appeared that he
shevchenko was the one who was not doing
his job as he should
this would not do the assistant director
launched into a long tirade
surrounded as we are by hostile
capitalist nations
we are forced to industrialize our great
country in the shortest possible time
leaving no stone unturned sparing no one
here we have assembled all the materials
and equipment for two new blast furnaces
they must be erected and blown in at the
earliest possible date and yet if i were
to believe you
i would be forced to think that the
whole job must be held up
for a lack of a few rivets or perhaps
you're not interested perhaps you remain
unconvinced by the last 15 years
shivchenko's rhetoric carried him away
his face was flushed his arm extended
then having asserted himself having
placed the party line before the old
wrecker and the foreign specialist
thus acquitting himself of the obvious
political obligation under the
circumstances
he took one of mr harris's cigarettes
drew stool up to the table
and proceeded to look over the list of
materials that the american had made out
there was no question about it of course
no amount of proletarian enthusiasm no
speeches
could take the place of the inch and a
half
rivets
that night outside of the barrack the
wind howled dismally
but in our little room it was warm
this was the magnetogorsk of 1933
a quarter of a million souls communists
kulaks foreigners
tartars convicted saboteurs and a mass
of blue-eyed russian peasants
making the biggest steel plant in europe
in the middle
of the barren ural steppe money was
spent like water
men froze hungered and suffered but the
construction work
went on with a disregard for individuals
and a mass heroism seldom paralleled
in history
the purge struck magneto gorsk in 1937
with great force
thousands were arrested incarcerated for
months finally exiled
no group no organization was spared
[Music]
for centuries russia was governed and
administered with the help of a secret
police
their methods were traditionally clumsy
brutal and inefficient
it was considered worthwhile to condemn
nine innocent defendants
in order to get one guilty one sometimes
whole villages of innocent people were
destroyed in order to get some
guilty peasant leader for centuries the
attitude towards foreigners was one of
fear
and mistrust the october revolution
changed many things in russia but the
above-mentioned
century-long traditions and habit
patterns are still present in the soviet
union
they conditioned the character and
successful execution of the purge
which might well have caused an
insurrection or a civil war
in england or the united states a large
number of spies saboteurs and fifth
columnists
were exiled or shot during the purge but
many more
innocent men and women were made to
suffer by 1935
chevchenko the assistant director had
been promoted to the post of manager of
the koken chemical plant
he received the order of lenin and was
made a member of the district party
committee
in 1935 his friend mary asin already
working on another job was arrested as
an
agent of the japanese secret service and
an active trotskyite
from that time on shepchenko was worried
took to drinking more than was good for
him and
made even more ardent speeches at
meetings
then a worker arrived from some town in
the ukraine and began to tell stories
about shivchenko's activities there in
1920.
shivchenko gave the man money and a good
job but still the story leaked out
one day about a year later shivchenko
was removed from his post
along with half dozen of his leading
personnel shivchenko was tried 15 months
later and got 10 years
shevchenko was at least 50 percent
bandit a dishonest and unscrupulous
careerist
however in all probability shivchenko
was not a japanese spy
[Music]
soviet purge techniques were highly
developed
all arrests were made at night surprise
was always sought for
people were arrested when they least
expected it and left alone for weeks
when they expected every night to be
taken
the arrests were made by agents having
no idea of the accusations against the
person
being arrested after someone's arrest
the family was usually left completely
in the dark for several weeks
while the arrested was put in the
magnetogorsk prison to cool off and
think things through
prior to the first investigation several
weeks after the arrest the family
usually received a formal notice that
the husband or brother had been arrested
and that the family could come at such
and such a time with a package
they suggested that the package should
contain warm clothes clean underwear
sugar onion and garlic the latter were
to combat scurvy which became rather
common in the prison owing to the
predominantly bred
on water diet and the lack of fresh air
in magnetogorsk in 1937 the activities
of the nkvd were often characterized by
great confusion
in cases where a numbers of responsible
workers and functionaries had been
arrested at the same time or
within a few days of each other
production suffered heavily for a while
after shivchenko's removal and the rest
for example
the coke and chemical output went down
sharply for several weeks
during the first few days chaos reigned
in the plant
a foreman would come to work in the
morning and say to his men
now today we must do this and that the
workers would sneer at him and say
go on you're a wrecker yourself tomorrow
they'll come and arrest you
all you engineers and technicians are
wreckers
and indeed alexey ivanovich pushkarf
the chief of the magnetogorsk nkvd
during 1937
was himself purged in 1939 for his
excessive enthusiasm in purging the
people of magnetogorsk
i left magneto gorsk with considerable
regret
i put in five of the most active years
of my life in its mills
my fingers that helped mold the blast
furnaces i had sweated in the heat of
summer frozen my nose and cheeks in the
arctic winter winds
i'd watched millions of tons of iron and
steel roll out of magneto gorsk
to soviet machine building and armament
works
when i left magneto gorsk i was
profoundly shocked by the fact that so
many people i had known
had been arrested the whole thing seemed
stupid
unreasonable preposterous the stalinist
constitution of 1936 had promised a
democratic and free society instead
the nkvd seemed to have run away with
the show
the purge appeared to be consuming
everything that had been created
i mentioned this to my russian friend
shimitshkin when i went around to bid
him goodbye
if i am not mistaken he said you and
america
tolerated chattel slavery for nearly a
century after your great constitution of
freedom went into force
your elections were travesties of
universal suffrage during the first
decades after your revolution
our soviet constitution is a blueprint
of the future
it is a picture of what we are building
and we will build it too
now our elections are ludicrous of
course civil liberties are restricted
but we are not yet one generation old
and we are at war now
do not forget it
[Music]
one conclusion i reached before i left
magneto gorsk i still believed to be
sound
westerners have no place in russia
it is the russians country and it is
their revolution
men and women from western europe and
america may occasionally succeed in
understanding it
but it is almost impossible for them to
fit into it
i survived black bread rotten salt fish
the cold the hard work which was
unusual i did not survive the purge
i think i understood it its causes its
inevitability in
uber gang's period russia but i could
not live with it
i probably could not have stuck it out
even had it tolerated me
i went to moscow and became an observer
which was
perhaps all i had ever been really